what up space fam golden here from anime
uproar back at it again with another
demonstrator video and since you guys
like the why everyone is afraid of
tundra videos so much and nezuko had
some epic moments recently in the anime
i thought it was the perfect time to
discuss nezuko and why she too is
special and fearsome if you do enjoy
these videos and want to keep them
coming then you know what to do share
the hush with it and smash that like
button with no mercy remember smash that
like button hashtag energy and passing
is scared moose on energy so choose
wisely if you haven't make this the
video subscribe and hit that
notification bell to turn on all
notifications or you will miss future
demonstrator videos and updates now a
quick thank you to displayed for
sponsoring this video this plate is the
leading marketplace for the highest
quality metal posters and i've been a
very satisfied customer of this blade
for many years they have millions of
different designs available in all
possible areas including anime and manga
gaming sports movies and more i already
own a bunch of their metal posters
including this amazing rain goku poster
and i absolutely love them this play
provides the highest quality prints on
metal there are so many great choices
that reflect your own unique hobbies and
passions and you can mount them on the
wall in just a few seconds with the help
of a magnet so no other tools are
necessary i chose a few of my favorite
displays for you guys to see so check
them out by clicking the link in the
description you can use the link in my
description to get an instant discount
at checkout and every time you buy
something using that link you are not
only getting an awesome poster but
you're also directly supporting this
channel at the same time just click that
top link in the description to check out
this plate right now and now without
further ado let's jump into its spoilers
and all immediately we knew nezuko was a
special demon because she didn't need to
eat humans to survive and she could also
escape muzon's grasp and control over
her just like tamayo did obviously that
alone irritates muzon the king of demons
but nezuko really starts to impress
demon power-wise when she awakens her
blood demon art against lower moon rui
even before that tamayo noted that
nezuko improved quickly and dramatically
when she fought against the balls demon
but tamiya still knew that she wasn't
ready to defeat that demon yet similarly
with rui she gets caught in his strings
and is not the star of the fight per se
but she does play a key role in helping
tanjiru as tundra is about to have his
head sliced off by rui's powerful
threads nezuko activates her blood demon
art exploding blood as the name
indicates her blood is set on fire as we
see it engulf all of rui's threads
including the ones that were about to
cut tundra's face her demon art is
described by the narrator as flammable
demon blood with an explosive
supernatural quality lower moon rui is
shocked that the fire was strong enough
to burn away his threads the key word
here is fire as we'll later find out
demonstrator wording is very important
flames are associated with kyogre and
goku's flame breathing style which is
derived from the first ever breathing
style created by the strongest
demonstrating history yorichitsugikuni
kyodro could not help tundra himself
with understanding the dance of the fire
god aka hinokami kagura because fire
breathing if we want to call it that is
not the same as flame breathing fire
breathing is actually called sun
breathing as we learn later and it was
passed down to tundra and his ancestors
through the dance of the fire god
tundra's family a family of coal burners
is thus associated with the fire god and
the strongest breath style so it's no
wonder looking back that nezuko's blood
demon art turned out to be fire just as
it's no surprise tundra's breathing
turned out to be sun aka fire breathing
and esco's fire shares properties with
the sun too in that it doesn't hurt
humans but will burn demons and what
they produce like threads or poisons
furthermore some of her blood was on
tundra's broken sword and when it
exploded it pushed tundra's nichiren
sword forward and gave him the power to
cut through to his neck keyword there is
the power to do it because as we find
out he doesn't actually do it since rui
detaches his own head first we can't say
tundra or nezuko are very strong at this
point in the story relatively speaking
since they would have lost the slower
moon if water hashra giu didn't show up
and effortlessly take care of the demon
that was giving them so much trouble
still we got a glimpse into the epicness
and specialness to come and in nezuko's
case we really see her bloom demon
power-wise in her fight against daki the
fight we just witnessed in the new anime
season and we should keep in mind that
like tanjiro nezuko is improving over
the course of the story so it can be
assumed that her fire burns stronger and
takes longer to regenerate from as the
story progresses keep in mind when
nezuko enters the fight against daki
it's because tundra was about to die you
could say tenjo's about to defeat daki
for a second but his avatar like yorichi
state is interrupted by the fact that he
went beyond his limits for too long and
wasn't even breathing he went from being
about to win to being paralyzed by the
pain of pushing himself too hard he was
completely at docky's mercy and so
nezuko decided to help and delivers an
epic kick against daki by the way just a
fun fact it's actually a really good
thing that tundra didn't cut her neck at
this point because then yutaro would
have shown up earlier and he would not
be so easy to occupy until the others
arrived so back to nezuko and you can
tell she's angry with all the sweat and
popping veins the reason she's so angry
and pumped up here is that daki contains
such a high concentration of muzon's
blood so it's stirring her memories of
when she lost her family to the demon
king all the revenge she wants to take
on muzon is being awakened here and
focused on daki nezuku is clearly on
muzan's mind too since when she sees her
doki realizes that nezuko is the one
muzon told her about the narrator also
tells us that human beings have limits
but demons don't thus nezuko's anger
burns just as hot but it has no
limitations her anger is infinite it
drives her on until she wipes her enemy
from the face of the earth and in this
case that enemy is docky additionally we
find out that just like he wants the
special earrings wearing tundra dead
he's telling his demons in this case
daki to find and finish off nezuko the
demon who escaped his grip clearly just
as with tanjiro he views nezuko as a
threat that must be dealt with and can't
be ignored at first it looks bad for
nezuko after all daki is an upper moon
or at least part of an upper moon so she
is strong she slices up nezuko and sends
her flying into a building daki assumes
that nezuko's weak because she doesn't
feed on humans and oh boy is she ever
wrong daki says a half-developed demon
like nezuko won't quickly regenerate
from those wounds but nezuko does to
dock his shock donkey cutter in half and
that should definitely take more time to
heal from daki starts to notice that the
speed of our nezuko's regeneration is
that of an upper ranked moon now this
relatively early into the story our
nezuko being compared to an upper moon
is so hyped but that's not where it
stops nezuko goes on to transform into a
new form she hits puberty like a brick
wall and even develops a cool looking
horn on the right side of her forehead
she also now has vine patterns all over
her body further suggesting that she
bloomed metaphorically vines are also
associated with the sun because they
need the sun to grow so another possible
connection to the sun there at this
point daki is afraid of nezuko asking
herself what's that feeling her menacing
aura has changed end quote nezuko
launches another kick one of my favorite
attacks in the story daki cuts her leg
like last time but nezuko just
immediately regrows the leg as if
nothing happened and finishes the kick
again doki's shocked by nezuko's
regeneration powers stating it's
impossible that she regenerated
instantly because that would make her
regenerative powers even greater than
donkeys but it's true meaning that
nezuko has even more power than doki
already in this form nezuku is even
stronger than tundra in this specific
point in the story and as we'll see
later i think she had to be taken out of
this battle or it wouldn't have been
challenging enough for her side i
absolutely love this powerful nesco
forum but it does come at a cost at
least initially and that cost is she
stops being herself and becomes more
like a wild bloodthirsty animal vampire
docky tries everything but nezuko is
wrecking her that's the only way to put
it doki tries cutting nezuko but she
just instantly regenerates she tries to
trap her in her sash but nezuko uses her
blood demon art to set daki on fire and
this releases her from daki sash as well
again daki doesn't say flames but and i
quote fire on burning end quote then
nezuko proceeds to repeatedly stomp on a
burning donkey in a merciless way i know
it's supposed to be disturbing too how
much desco is losing it but it's also
just so awesome at the same time she
then kicks burnt and beat up donkey into
a building and this is where things get
complicated she sees bleeding humans and
in this form she can prevent herself
from attacking them she sweats and
salivates at the sight of human blood
but as she lunges at them tundra comes
to the rescue restraining nezuko with
his sword and his sheath against daki
nezuku definitely proved that she could
be feared by demons but it's not hard to
understand why this feral version of her
freaks out humans as well and of course
tundra giu and urokodaki fear nothing
more than her becoming a murderer by
taking an innocent human life nezuko
even gives tundra a pretty good
thrashing as she's trying to escape she
jumps with an incredible force and
smashes tundra's back through the
ceiling nezu is clearly more powerful
than tangent or here who's barely
holding her back in the meantime we see
doki's face which is still burnt it goes
to show how strong nazco's fire has
become it should not take this long for
donkey to heal but just as dance of the
fire god attacks and bright red blades
make it harder for demons to regenerate
than normal breathing attacks it seems
that nezuko's fire is harder to recover
from than normal demon arts again this
is probably in part because it
represents and is tied to the idea of
the sun and the fire god doki straight
up says even for me it'll take a while
to heal all this very impressive stuff
from nezuko here tengen shows up finally
and calls daki too weak to be an upper
moon in a split second without daki even
seeing it coming tengen cut off her head
showing that tangent the hasher is
pretty impressive because tundra was
struggling hard and almost dying himself
against daki we can't really judge how
nezuko did compare to tangent because
yes tengen finished her off quicker but
nezuko has no way to finish her off
without a naturian blade or the sun she
did utterly overpower donkey though
which is all she can really be expected
to do as a demon this is just a
possibility but i find it interesting
perhaps nezuko's fire if used enough
could like the sun actually finish off a
demon for instance it would be
interesting if we saw her use it against
a really weak demon just to see if it's
possible nutrient blades can end a demon
so why not this fire ability from the
chosen demon however that is pure
speculation and she never actually
killed a demon with her fire i'm just
saying i wouldn't be surprised if this
blood demon art that comes from a fire
god worshiping family could kill a demon
in its final most powerful incarnation
just like nietzsche and blades tangent
ends up helping tangio calm nezuko down
he suggests singing her a lullaby and it
actually does the trick leave it to the
sound hasha to know the power of
soothing sounds and nostalgic music
nezuko starts crying and reverts back
into her adorable little form she goes
to sleep and that's really it for nesco
this arc except for a brief reappearance
at the end of the fight like i said the
writer needed to put her to sleep here
because it would have been too one-sided
if they had this nezuko to help take
down daking yutaro but to be fair
tendril did mention she lost a lot of
blood and this was her first time
unlocking this new form so it does make
logical sense that she'd need to sleep
for a while to recover from all that
although everyone arguably gets stronger
over the course of this battle
especially tanjiro it's noteworthy that
zanitsu and inosuke together have
trouble taking on daki initially despite
the fact that they are working together
in fact it is only when tendril joins in
to help them that they succeed in taking
her head for the first time and inosuke
runs with it like it was a football
until he gets hit unexpectedly by
gyutaro who just seemingly finished off
tanget the reason i bring this up is
that it took tundra inosuke and zenitsu
working together here to overpower doki
while nezuko did it on her own and there
was an even more pronounced gap between
their powers admittedly doki does say
she's more powerful with guterre awake
but still it presumably can't be that
much more powerful if your was being
occupied with another fight so it could
be argued that nezuko grew so fast
power-wise that at this point at least
she surpassed the zanitsu enosuke
working together and perhaps even tied
the power of all three of the
demon-slaying amigos working together
she's easily the strongest of the four
at the end of the fight it's arguably a
different story especially with tundra's
evolving demon slayer mark sun breathing
avatar estate thing going on that lets
him cut through gyutaro's neck however
it's true that we didn't see the limits
of what this new form nezuko was capable
of since she was taken out of battle
after easily wrecking daki furthermore
nezuko wakes up near the end of the
fight and she seems completely fine
after losing all that blood and
unlocking a new form she saves tanjiro
from yutoro's final attack her fire also
heals the poison tainted skin of
tanjoynosuke and tangen saving all three
of their lives especially tengen since
this dude couldn't even talk anymore and
he was pretty much at death's door so
yeah nezuku saved the day with no sign
of exhaustion on her she was arguably
the most impressive character of the arc
and that's why she had to be taken out
of the battle for a while to let the
others shine and make the fight more
interesting thus i'd say nezko is
already upper moon level here as doki
pointed out when discussing her
regeneration abilities and she continues
to get more impressive and keep in mind
upper moons are supposed to beat hashira
one on one which is why the upper moons
didn't change in over a century since it
was suggested that daki ate multiple
hashra in the story we can assume that
nezuko hurak daki could beat certain
hashira too at this point side note as i
always say it appears this generation of
hashra is stronger than others because
gootaro was more impressed by tengen
than he was by the hashra he killed in
the past and in my view and his own
tengen is one of the weaker hashra of
this generation luckily nezuko vs
orhashira never has to be put to the
test since she's on the good side and
not only is her growing physical power
now an annoyance to moves on but the
blood demon art fire is also something
to worry about since it can hurt demons
in a way that reduces regeneration
powers and as we saw it can heal people
who would have otherwise died from demon
poison i also don't want to make the
mistake of overhyping nezuko's power at
this point in the story since she does
meet more than her match against upper
moon 4han tengu who in all fairness is
very strong nevertheless nezuko makes
some significant progress in this fight
the fight starts with tundra genya and
nezuko taking on hantengu's clones with
their different powers like electricity
wind sound and flying nezuko quickly
changes into her horned form and this
time seems to be in much better control
of it which is pretty standard shown in
logic nezuko is harder to deal with than
the clones expect a clone is impressed
by what a powerful kick nezuko can
deliver she then proceeds to burn him
and sends him flying with the wind
powers of a fan weapon so she did out
fight at least that one clone but then
she's hit with the staff of the other
which runs electricity through her it
won't kill her since she's a demon but
it will keep her from moving as long as
the electricity keeps running through
her it's interesting seeing what demons
end up doing against other demons to
take them down or keep them from
interfering since they don't have a way
outside of the sun to actually kill each
other tundra comes and saves nezuko from
the electricity staff nezuko returns the
favor and stops the staff before it can
penetrate tanjuro and sets the clone on
fire the clone is clearly in pain and
comments on what a tricky move this fire
is tundra can't help but think that the
fire is incredible and nezuko's blood is
doing the trick clearly dealing with one
of these clones hasn't been that
challenging for nezuko but then the fan
one comes back and the force of his wind
attack sends nezuko and tundra falling
to the bottom floor and releases the
burning clone from the fire it seems at
the very least like electricity the fire
can immobilize a clone but it would have
been interesting seeing what would
happen if it kept going since tundra
said it was doing the trick perhaps if
used long enough the clone might have at
least looked like docky and take it
longer to regenerate but as things stand
he looks fine after being released from
the fire back to the fight and from the
fan attack tundra passed out and when he
comes to nezuku is carrying him and
trying to run away from the clone
attacks as a demon it obviously makes
sense that desco can take more damage
than tundra and recover quicker as
they're wondering what they're gonna do
nezuko uses her blood to set tundra's
black sword on fire and it becomes
bright red the strongest color and the
most effective against demons as you
already noticed nezuko really shines in
a team like right here yeah she is
strong individually but a big part of
her strength is also making the team
stronger like giving tundra a super
effective blade to use healing the
others from guterre's poison using her
super effective fire that only hurts
demons while the demon stairs are free
to fight on without worry saving
tundra's butt over and over again and so
on she's an insanely valuable asset to
the demon slayers and that's another
reason why muzon wants her gone in
addition to her being a living symbol of
his power not being absolute since she
escaped his grip and the red blade and
the upgrade that accompanies it allows
tundra to take down three clones and
they regenerate slower because of the
burning associated with the red blade
genya takes down the fourth but that's
not enough because those aren't the real
body tundra and escort strong enough now
together to distract the other clones
long enough for genya to find the real
body but genya is not strong enough to
take its head tundra tries to take the
head but even he can since the effect of
nezuko's blood has worn off once again
it is nezuko who saves tundra from the
strongest clone yet the hatred clone
that resulted from the combination of
the other four aside from being able to
use wood manipulation in the form of
giant wooden dragons this clone can use
the blood demon arts of the other clones
as well and he's unkillable unless you
get the real body which is somewhere
else hiding the hatred clone is insanely
powerful and its mere presence is so
overpowering that it makes it difficult
for tundra to breathe and it makes his
heart hurt similarly genjia feels the
pressure and his limbs feel weak and he
can barely stand as the hatred clone
mentions humans aren't the only ones
whose strength can surge and upper moon
4 is getting stronger when hantengu the
original body is pressed into tight
spots like this one that's a quick
detail but it's important to note
potentially they could have already
taken care of how strong upper moon 4
was when the fight started but the
problem is upper moon 4 keeps evolving
and getting stronger based on the stench
of blood tundra believes that upper moon
4 has probably eaten 200 people and for
demons the more they eat the stronger
they're supposed to get it's no surprise
then that nezuko is not stronger than
this hatred clone here in fact nezuko
genya and tundra working together are
not strong enough to take it on as the
five wooden dragon heads keep launching
their attacks at one point it looks like
all three are done for but then mitsuri
the love hashira comes to the rescue in
the end it takes mitsuri with an
awakened demon slayer mark which is
pretty much like going super saiyan for
a demon slayer to hold the hatred clone
back long enough for the others to go
after the real body even then she almost
loses but luckily as we'll get to they
managed to cut off the real head in the
nick of time as they're chasing the real
body nezuko helps save tundra another
time using her fire then the time for a
difficult decision comes the sun is
rising the real body is approaching
innocent villagers to replenish its
strength tundra has to decide whether
he'll keep covering nezuko from the sun
or save the innocent humans from the
demon he is paralyzed from indecision he
can't decide so it looks like he'll just
stay with nezuko but then nezuko makes
the decision for him by launching him
into the air it looks like she'll burn
in the sun and tundra with tears in his
eyes finally slices the main body it
looks like it's the end for nezuko but
then it's revealed that nezuko has
become the first demon to be immune to
the sun aka to conquer the sunlight upon
learning this muzon is ecstatic because
he hopes by absorbing her he can become
immune too he calls nezuko the chosen
demon and this immunity to the sun a
rare condition that never even appeared
in the 12 kizuki aka demon moons so
that's one way nezuko already surpassed
even the stronger upper moons nezu is so
important now that muzon foresees a
massive battle with nezuko at its center
unfortunately everyone hoping for
nezuko's incredible growth and power and
fighting potential to continue will be
disappointed at this point instead she
is given medicine by tamayo so that she
can become fully human again this
medicine is hard on her and she's
bedridden as a result and looked after
by urokodaki until the transformation to
human is complete now it's great that
nesco becomes human again that was the
goal after all and the mangaka and demon
slayer is not one to glorify power and
would prefer her characters even
weakened to live a simple happy life as
humans which i respect however that
means nezuko stops growing power wise
and when she returns to being human as
you can imagine she's much weaker than
she was in her demon form and is not
really a combatant anymore still it must
be said her potential was crazy at
certain points as we saw she was
outpacing tanjiro zanitsu and inosuke in
power like when she embarrassed daki
with her new form she learned to control
that form and she would have been able
to grow more and potentially beat almost
any demon by dragging out the fight long
enough until the sun came out as
mentioned not any upper moon not even
muzon was able to conquer the sun as
nezuko did she surpassed them all in
that way there's no telling how much
stronger the chosen demon would have
gotten if she'd unlock stronger forms
how strong her blood demon art would
eventually become and so on as doki
mentioned the only way most demons could
beat her was by exposing her to the sun
but this would no longer work so she'd
be practically unkillable that being
said muzon is known to absorb demons and
wanted to absorb her so he could have
potentially beat her but besides that
she could have grown in power along with
tundra and potentially could have
defended herself against him in battle
or at least against the remaining upper
moons as things turned out though tanjo
kept getting stronger and she didn't so
nezuko did have frightening potential
and was feared by demons and humans
alike at certain points in the story she
had a rapid rate of growth and just like
there was a point where tundra was about
to become the demon king nezuku could
have become a demon queen when muzon was
talked about tundra being able to
conquer the sunlight and become the
strongest demon the king of demons he
mentioned that this is possible because
he is the elder brother of nezuko and
thus shares her blood and he's right
tundra goes on to conquer the sun just
like nezuko which means that we can take
tundra's potential to become the
strongest demon and conquer decapitation
by nichiren blade 2 and apply it to
nezuko as well since as muzan says they
share the same blood so yeah tundra had
demon king potential and nezu had demon
queen potential before her brother even
became a demon like with tanjuro her
immunity to the sun would have meant
that bright red blades wouldn't be
effective as they are against all the
upper moons and even moves on and as i
mentioned i respect the mangaka story
and decision to value the simple happy
life over becoming stronger and stronger
at all costs but a part of me still
wishes we got to see nesco's full demon
queen potential because it would have
been terrifyingly powerful even if she
ended up becoming a human in the end
anyways but yeah that is it for this
video about why demon queen nezuko is so
fear-worthy especially when we look at
what could have been if her insane and
rapid rate of growth wasn't suddenly
halted while tundras continued if you
did enjoy this video and you want to
keep them coming you know what to do
channel demonstrate within and smash
that like button with no mercy remember
smashing that like button is demonstrate
energy and passing is scared moose on
energy so choose wisely if you haven't
make this the video you subscribe and
hit that notification bell to turn on
all notifications or you will miss
future demonstrator videos and updates
and while you wait for the next video to
drop feel free to check out my huge and
growing demonstrator playlist that
includes videos on why everyone is
afraid of tanjiro all the hashira all
the demon moons and much more link to
that is in the description leave
suggestions for future video ideas that
will set your heart ablaze and until
next time see ya space cowboys